i think you should leave this one
welcome to the space jam put your hands
in the air
copyright strikes at this part
can't hum hey trying to get a stupid
size jam a new legacy trailer number
one john and i we grew up on the classic
michael jordan film are you excited for
this yeah matt i hope wayne knight's
back i hope
bill murray's back i hope that all the
looney tunes are back
we've been excited for this since that
leaked footage that came out with
joker and pennywise pages ago those are
the people i wanted to space out that's
all
like get them on the basketball team
yeah let's see what's in store
i'm very excited i'm excited too king
james let's do this
you excited to fly like an eagle let's
go to the sea
basketball campus next weekend you got
amazing potential on the court
and i can help you get there that's not
what i would do
you never let me do what i wouldn't do
you never let me just
do me hmm overbearing father
actually playing into it this time
space jam is 20 20 we've gone to the
future
matrix hell whoa doctor strange
game of thrones yeah you see it yo
this is so cool
that's dawn shields yeah
the only way you're getting your son
back
send this is to the rejects reach
nation
[Music]
oh 2d a 2d animation
[Music]
always going for the iron giant in these
movies
this 2d looks classic
guns where lola bunny has to change her
up
there's so many people
whoa
[Music]
my truck
oh
[Music]
uh
right classic
humor classic jokes
old lady doing some gymnastics cause old
ladies can't do that old ladies
normally can't do that not but that old
lady i know that would take
too many old women and you'd be
surprised
yeah no old women and children no one my
age
wow mr humphrey yeah i
that looks like it looks really cool
i had a feeling to be fun entertaining
it's all that looks like it it's
spiritually very much aware of what it
is
i'm loving it and lebron james looks
like he's actually doing a pretty good
job with the acting too
yeah he looks like he's meeting the
movie where it is and giving it his
all and then treating it yeah with with
an earnest seriousness
i and sincerely though you know it's
like michael jordan's fun to watch in
space jam
but you know like let's face it he
wasn't the greatest actor not the actor
lebron james is touted to be but you
haven't seen lebron james here let me
know there's somebody here for
serious parts of this trailer you
actually look pretty believable
so i guess what i wasn't expecting to
walk away from this trailer
is i think i'm going to cry from the
draw now
what it's going to be is cooler than i
expected it to
so many characters in this trailer
that's why that's what space jam was
really missing was game of thrones
well that whole sequence has a super
ready player one shot
yeah a lot of this reminded me of ready
player one but just with like much more
whimsy to get the iron giant in there
and to have kong in there in that same
like moving shot you're like oh that's
straight out already player one
and uh i don't see joker in here but
where's this shot with don
cheadle because it looked like there
were so many people behind him i want to
see who we can point out who we got
mr freeze there's pennywise right there
the wizard of oz
monkey agent smith is uh this drogo
caldrogue that could be cal drogo i
think i got the name i think it's drogon
oh not drogo but she named him in honor
of drunk that's what it was there you go
see you're spiritually correct i'm
spiritually correct but everyone's gonna
be like this guy is the new game of
thrones you're supposed to know game of
thrones
right off the bat the second you watch
your spaceship that's the point of this
trailer
identify your game of thrones knowledge
oh you got the flintstones in here you
got
all the classic wb jetsons man magilla
gorilla there's a lot of hannah barbera
in here
i think like the visual effects were so
much cooler than i expected them to be
what felt like very
modern day when the sun first gets lost
and it feels like
space jam 2021 this is what the updated
version would look like
and my first time like it looks good
looks cool kind of like the darker
aesthetic and this you know whatever
role don cheadle has is the villain
kind of like annette benning and captain
marvel is what i was thinking of but
having that at first i was like
i don't know about this yeah and once i
got into the 2d animation and then
passed the 2d animation
and then opening up the world i got to
admit like i was dazzled that was a
sense of wonder
yeah i mean it reached that level of
goofy wild
whimsical fun that you want out of a
space jam because i was right there with
you when the trailer started i was like
ah here here we go
i'm already missing the sort of
quaintness of getting sucked down like
the
you know little golf hole or whatever
but yeah once it gets into
the full-on fantasy of it and you are
oscillating between animation styles and
you've got you know
lebron james turning into 2d you've got
the 2d characters turning into 3d
it does look like an extravaganza that
is just trying to
throw as many fun and goofy things that
you would possible and that's all space
jam really needs to be
one of those movies that has this weird
nostalgia factor where i think you go
back and watch the original space jam
and while it does have a certain charm i
think it's easier to see
now that like oh yeah that's not the
smoothest movie in the world
i'm interested to see how this turns out
because it seems like they have room to
improve and make a
a better film but at the same time they
have everything you could want here from
a space
jam movie you've got all the animation
styles you've got more characters than
you could
pause and name it from this trailer
alone even like the basketball like i
was afraid that that was gonna be sort
of a
shoehorned sort of like how do we
justify doing this but even that looked
like fun by the end of it you know
yeah i know there's so much happening
that that the focus of the basketball
game seems to be the last thing
happening yeah i was like we got a shoe
horn a basketball game in here somewhere
yeah whereas in the first one i mean i'm
sure that'll be the actual central focus
point of all this you got lebron james
in here it's space jam i guess the other
thing i wasn't expecting to walk away
with besides saying this is cool is this
looks
epic it has this epic scale to it
everything just looks like there's the
stakes look
so high and it seemed like it didn't
play
heavily into the comedy and more into
the scope of everything that they're
doing i gotta point out too
one thing that i laugh at every time i
watch the first space jam movie
is michael jordan seems like he just
doesn't really give a [ __ ] about his son
you seem like you you could care less
about getting back to your kid
you just want to get back to playing
your game uh in the real world
here it's all about trying to trying to
save his kid
that's the vibe i got yeah trying to
save his kid and also i'm sure
probably trying to connect with him in a
way that allows him to flourish with his
own interests and not be forced into the
family basketball business
do you think kong went to the hollow
earth
and this is this is what the uh the
house hello
earth is toontown all right guys what
did you think about the space jam new
legacy trailer subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button
patron of the day shout
bradley bledsoe bradley if i
was sucked down a hole into toontown and
i needed to play a competitive
sport against cartoon classics to save
the lives of myself
as well as my young son who doesn't want
to follow in my footsteps who am i
calling for my team
you you're like a living cartoon
character brad
you have such a colorful personality
whenever i think of your face i don't
think of you know
skin and human flesh and all that i just
think of like 2d
animated bradley you know all you had to
say was that he just had a daughter
persephone so imagine if
what if your daughter persephone got
sucked into toon
world and then and then you had to go
after her he would be the kind of guy
and you would tell me how to kind of go
with i just i'm just saying that you
said let's do bradley i'm like oh yeah
that makes sense and then you took it
in a very different direction that's
what i'm here for what if space jam was
your
life bradley shout out completed
love you be well